let's take 63 and divide it by 35 so the
first thing that we might say is okay
well 35 doesn't go into 6 it does go
into 63 it goes into 63 one time because
2 times 35 is 70 so that's too big so it
goes one time so let me write that it
goes one time one times 35 is 35 and
then if we were to subtract and we can
regroup up here we can take a 10 from
the 60 so it becomes a 50 give that 10
to the 3 so it becomes a 13 13 minus 5
is 8 5 minus 3 is 2 so you could just
say hey 63 divided by 35 let me write
this you could say 63 divided by 35 is
equal to 1 remainder 28 1 remainder 28
but this isn't so satisfying we know
that the real answer is going to be 1
point something something something so
what I want to do is keep dividing I
want to divide this thing completely and
see what type of a decimal I actually
get and to do that I essentially have to
add a decimal here and then just keep
bringing down decimal places to the
right of the decimal so 63 is the exact
same thing as 60 3.0 and I could add as
many zeros as I might want to add here
so what we could do is we just make sure
that this decimal is right over there if
we can now bring down a zero from the
tens place right over here and you bring
down that zero and now we ask ourselves
how many times is 35 go into 280 and as
always this is a bit of an art when
you're dividing a two-digit number into
a three-digit number so let's see it's
definitely going to be let's see if I
were to say so for 40 goes into 287
times 30 goes into 280 about goes about
9 times it's going to be between 7 & 9
so let's let's try 8 so let's see what
35 times 8 is 35 times 8 5 times 8 is 40
3 times 8 is 24 plus 4 is 28 so it
actually works out perfectly so 35 goes
into 280 exact
exactly eight times eight times five we
already figured it out eight times
thirty-five is exactly 280 and we don't
have any remainder now so we don't have
to bring down any more of these zeros so
now we know exactly that 63 divided by
35 is equal to exactly one point eight